[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to track B again
I'm Sonia and I'm really excited we have
Jeff Hoffer here today give our our next
talk I'm really excited about it when I
was chatting well we asked you know Jeff
to share with us some something that you
know people might not know about him and
he he mentioned that he is a really loud
clapper so when I heard this I was like
I also am a really loud clapper so
obviously we have to have a clap off
right all right are you ready
we both practiced a little bit yesterday
so so you ready you want to go first why
do I have to go first
I mean I was gonna just gonna give you
the honor you're our guest here ladies
first
all right all right all right okay all
right it's about Palm death and moisture
okay so there's there she's thought
about this a lot more than I I really
have so it's pretty loud all right all
right maybe I should have gone first I'm
stressing now mine's more like an
audience applause clap thank you for you
[Applause]
exceptional claps I think we have some
competition I know definitely some good
loud clappers out there well thank you
all and without further ado Jeff hopper
thank you thanks everybody for joining
the lights are really bright so if I'm
looking down the whole time that's
pretty much why also this is the first
time giving this talk so I hope that
there aren't moments that I just pause
completely and lose lose my train of
thought so bear with me so the talk is
we're the same you and me a new way to
align programming paradigms across
client and server less so the the the
this talk and the the concepts and ideas
in it are born out of years of
experience working in startups and
working on legacy systems and too often
working in a start-up on a legacy system
that is legacy way too quickly so I
imagine some of you can relate to that
and I hope there's some inspiration
there for all of us when when I talk
about a new way of programming to align
these paradigms and more generally
execution environments I am referring to
something I call the towel model or
towel programming paradigm and it has
three specific parts it provides a
message format three various ways to
handle messages and a signal network
it's the audio okay the towel model
derives its name from an acronym for the
message format to make it easy to
remember especially the ordering of the
parts and every message we're used to
messaging that specifies the action or
operation but the towel message differs
from traditional messaging in a few ways
specifically provides three degrees of
freedom which will make a lot more sense
when you see it using in wildcard
handlers also we embed the subject of
the message within the message itself
whereas most messaging systems or most
messaging we're used to this subject is
either the source or the destination of
the message and the inclusion of a third
dimension the orientation allowing us to
view the description and context of our
application from all angles not just a
two-dimensional view so the towel model
also provides three distinct ways in
which we can attach handlers to our
signal network in line handlers are
those that were most used to invented
systems they happen in an ordered
sequence and these are our order desired
effects but it also provides two other
mechanisms one is an async attachment so
that we can explicitly create
out-of-band
side-effects as well as an intercept
handler that allows us to halt operation
and add guards to our execution flow in
the towel model our trigrams describe
discrete application oh sorry in the
towel model our trigrams to describe
discrete application contexts we use a
signal network that connects those parts
that are generating these application
context to our handler code which is
observing and reacting to these
application contexts our signal network
also provides the ability to chain these
messages in a way simply by returning a
new application context to the signal
network from your handler in this way
our signal network is
implemented the same and has the same
interface no matter whether you're
executing it on the client or a server
or a server loose this the towel model
is currently implemented in JavaScript
under the name of Tao das there are
three packages on NPM published the core
implements the towel model itself and
provides the public API you can include
it in any package you want and start
using it right away
react package provides an adapter to
turn components into towel handlers as
well as a reactor component that will
react to the signal network and render
the correct the component that you'd
like the socket IO package implements
the signal network so that it spans
client and server so let's take a look
at some code y'all can see that okay
should I um
let me move all of these hides ease
how's that a little more a little more
better one bitter to bear one better to
I can't see an optometrist and not crack
up when I'm going through that so simply
tell Jo score we go ahead and import the
tau which is our signal network
implementation here and then there's
another piece that we can import is it
app CT X so that allows us to generate
application context that we can return
from a handler until the signal network
to chain down to this next message or
event or application context in addition
we for up for our server we are
importing our wire tau J s to suck at
i/o and that's all we need from there so
once our server is set up so this is a
KOA server attaching a socket IO for
each each socket that comes in we will
wire it up and use our unconnect method
in it client towel so on the server side
we need we actually end up with two
signal networks one that we can use to
handle all application contexts and ones
that are specific to our client so
whenever a connection occurs this one is
called back
and then we attach our handlers to it on
the client side specifically so our NIC
client ow we get the we get the new
client ow and it has an ID I'll ignore
that for now so we set up some inline
handlers that we need to occur on our
server our example application it's
super bare-bones just to be an example
so that you get the gist of what's
happening and I'm not dazzling you with
my terrible CSS so the concept of behind
it is it's a it's an application for
creating your own spaces of your own
vocabulary words and so it's going to
have spaces and phrases within those
spaces so for for now we're just using
the space as an example so on this we
have a term space an action of find and
our orientation is the portal that most
users will see so we have an async
operation where we're going to take what
we're being asked to find find can be
undefined or it could have a specific ID
which tells our handler to react in
different ways it will use our spaces to
go find the spaces if there's no
specific ID so it'll go get all of the
spaces or it'll return it'll find one
and return it directly if we encounter
any errors we set up in action we we
chain on towards a space of a fail and
we send that message on so that the
client can react so this is very basic
stuff go ahead and lose all that inside
of our web application
so up in here when the client loads
we're going to import this cow in it
which will give us an initial
application context to set to set the
wheels in motion within our signal
network that somebody has entered
entered the application that file looks
like this so this sets up our socket IO
connection and and and then sets up a
series of handlers that will occur as
where as the application is going so we
have an app enter portal app view the
portal session fine portal session
create portal so we add an inline
handler for when somebody enters the app
and we return a view application context
that we want to happen when the app view
portal happens we want to go find spaces
and we don't we don't specify any one
space by giving it an ID so it returns
everything these are old
so as we react to the find oh this is so
once that's how our find method our fine
kicks off what happens on the server so
this is going to respond with a list so
let me start fire these up and pray that
it works should it's pretty simple
it's my fault for commenting out things
I thought I didn't need
okay Cole you're back in actually I'm
just gonna put all this rest stuff back
in so when I first built that I was
testing it out with not using socket IO
but interacting with a REST API which
works just fine there we go now let's
welcome
something I didn't what's that yeah
that's probably probably the best idea
get reset head force force push
see
there we go thank you so what we see
here is and I will just clear the
console refresh a series of series of
events occur as we go through this
process of bootstrapping and rendering
our app good we initially we initially
set off the app enter portal which then
kicks off of trying to find a session
that exists and this is done we have an
async handler for that so we don't block
the app view from happening and we enter
the session when this is found we go
find spaces so that we can list them and
show the ListView
so showing how it integrates with react
in our app we see we simply are grabbing
space from our components and then
rendering it here so in our index here
what we're doing is creating a space
container and we have two different
reactor components that are exported
from our tower dot J's react package
along with the adapter the adapter we
use as a way of adapting we wrap our Tau
signal Network and then set a default
context so that all the all the
component handlers we set I'll use
determine Orient for space and portal so
we don't have to keep repeating those
and then if the action comes in as list
we want to show the list view the list
component if it's a view we want to have
the view component and if it's a new or
edit action we want to show the form
component now if you if you look here
each of these the view components are
just basic react components the space
view is a functional component it has
nothing to do with the Tau except for
using the signal Network to actually set
the context if somebody clicks a button
same with the list it's you know nested
components and then our form component
is you know extends component has an
editable state within it but it's it's
not doing anything with the tau other
than being a handler for an application
context and pretty prettier is
complaining
so if I knew save it we now have that
space and go back to the list can edit
it's there so all of the code is built
using the same paradigm for the
client-side as well as the server-side
and jump back to our presentation so all
of my friends and colleagues that have
shown this to say hey that's really cool
but they always ask me the same question
why do we want this as a as a plucky
recent college grad with my first
corporate job my first corporate boss I
was armed with design patterns as a
solution to all the coding and
architectural problems so when I noticed
that the team wasn't talking about
design patterns in any way and largely
nobody seemed to have heard of them I
went to my boss and I said hey I'd like
to give a presentation on design
patterns I think he would really help
the team I think it would really help us
the applications were building and he
responded with all software approaches a
state of entropy over time so I don't
see any point in design patterns thanks
true story I'm pretty sure he was
talking about the second definition here
since we were talking about how to build
project management software and customer
service software and as much as I didn't
like it he was right all software
systems do end up heading towards
entropy and states of disorder so we
have three major causes of entropy in
our applications most of which are born
out of this need to build and prove our
application and what we want to create
without incurring the overhead of
building it right even in cases where we
set off to build it right because we
have budget and time managing these
three factors through traditional
architectural and design patterns
attempt to control the entropy
microservices is another evolution in
this direction of controlling entropy
and systems but they come with
additional overhead requiring additional
tooling and support and infrastructure
in order to embrace them so what if we
embrace the entropy we know it's coming
what would what would it look like if we
could just embrace the entropy that's
coming in our system we would have to
plan to manage these three aspects of
entropy the tight coupling scaling
across processes and extending our
application beyond its original concept
so in the seminal work that started the
design patterns movement the Gang of
Four put a quote in there that was
designed to make us better developers
it's programmed to an interface and not
an implementation interesting in that in
an interview in 2005 Erich gamma one of
the art of
design patterns book spoke about
interfaces defining the vocabulary of
the collaboration of a system and how
understanding these interfaces you could
get an understanding of the underlying
problem of a system so if we want to
embrace him entropy by avoiding the
tight coupling and elaborating on Eric's
words we need a mechanism for
comprehensive interfaces comprehensive
has two definitions and we want to use
both of them we want our interfaces to
completely define our system while we
also want them to be easily understood
we end up spending time and effort
abstracting the fact that we are using a
REST API as a back-end from our client
app creating overhead and abstraction
for what we never end up swapping out
the REST API for something different
that takes too much time most often
these abstractions and interfaces we
create deal with the Hal of our system
through the point I've seen applications
that have a react client app with three
different mapping layers from Redux to
our component and this ends up just
creating a lot of overhead for the next
developer coming along that has to add
something to it this is where
domain-driven design can help us to find
the what of our system and focus our
interface attention where changes
towards disorder occur most and that is
in the what
so our towel message is the interface we
can use these trigrams of term action
and orient to create an interface
description that anyone else can easily
comprehend as well as create a handler
for it
and we generally think of terms as
entities in our domain from the main
drive in design but it can also
represent a relationship or other
term non domain term that is useful for
our applications by being distinct three
mesthri strings to represent a possible
application context the Tao trigrams are
not bounded to anything other than
representing what your app is doing now
when we're generating an event in our
system all it needs to do is provide
these specific application context of
the event this includes the Tao trigram
and the complete attached data that goes
along with it and our handlers are
called when the trigram matches what
they've subscribed to so they just wait
for the outcome and react to it we know
we have now resolved our tight coupling
problem with a simple mechanism for
defining interfaces that abstract of
what of our application and we didn't
choose a message driven paradigm by
accident the next problem to tackle
entropy in our system is to deal with
the scale problem this problem usually
has shows up in algorithms that are
written that aren't made to deal with
scale and they're deeply embedded and
they calcify to the point where once
it's time to scale we have to pull back
and find and rip these things out deep
within our application architecture so
to embrace the intro this entropic cause
we need to decouple scalability from our
system that we used to build the
application itself and we do this by
using an evented message oriented
architecture baked into the baked into
the towel through the signal network so
this is a quote from Wikipedia I
remember it slightly differently from my
object-oriented class in the reading in
in in college and I was struck by this
concept that when an object calls a
method on another object it is passing a
message to that object and
this original definition came from small
talk where it literally was passing a
message in the implementation but the
the metaphor and the abstraction is the
same so in essence we're already
building message oriented applications
we just don't seem to agree on the
message format and the messaging
paradigm itself so this is not a new
pattern but one which we have separated
client for back-end when we build our
event and message based systems event
that implementations written dated from
user interface designs long ago with the
observer pattern which that's our signal
Network uses to its advantage message
bus systems are prevalent in high skill
high scale backends and using message
buses and the the problem with that
generally that I've come across is that
whenever you decide to go with a message
oriented back-end you then have to
decide what is the format for our
messages every time by leveraging the
Tao trigram message we got the format
figured out it's dynamic enough that we
can allow it to work for any context in
any situation now the flux architecture
introduced a lot of people to the
concept of unidirectional data flow and
it's something that existed in backend
data processing for some time and it's
now a welcome addition and client side
development the DAO embraces
unidirectional data flow in that
handlers when you set the context on the
single network there is no return coming
back to the caller so there's nothing to
sit there and wait for so you're setting
a context and letting it propagate
through your system this allows us to
have a single paradigm across all the
execution environments
so now that we found a wave to decouple
scalability from our application
building system across all environments
to resolve the scale problem we can
embrace the entropy to come we need to
have a way to evolve our application
beyond its original intent again micro
services have come to our aid in this
department but once again on the side of
controlling entropy micro services as an
architectural choice move us back in the
direction towards korba and decom of
distributed components but in this case
we're running them in their own
processes they have ownership of their
own data and they leverage web standards
for their network and interface
definitions but what we're really
looking for is not just the
componentized development but a method
for adding or injecting extensions to
our application and our in our system
that we didn't think of while we were
building it this is to embrace entropy
many frameworks actually provide
extension points within them but all of
these extension points are tied to the
given framework and there's no
standardization across frameworks
there's no standardization of extension
mechanisms from client and server so
there are you guessed it three ways the
Tao implements dynamic extension points
if anybody's counting the number of
times I say three the first is the three
different types of message handlers the
intercept async and inline if you notice
I flipped the order from when I
introduced them at the beginning and
that is because this is in this is in
the priority order in which they are
executed by the signal network and this
gives us a way to deterministically
configure the order in which our
handlers will be called even though
they're added to the system dynamically
the second way is through while the
second way for dynamic extension is
through wildcard handlers so we can add
handlers that can handle in this case
anything anytime anything is added on
the admin or we could have a wildcard
for any of them any any application
context that comes through any message
and the third way is through this
chaining mechanism as we build our
application we're not going to think of
everything ahead of time and that's by
design
entropy occurs when our product managers
come to us and say well I need it to do
this now so we can now inject a new
event in our chain a new message in our
chain and then subscribe to that and add
a new handler and then thus not touching
anything between so aspect oriented
programming is a paradigm that allows a
separation of application logic from
what's called application wide or
cross-cutting concerns like security and
logging most AOP implementations provide
point cut systems that perform cross
compilation to inject code but they're
generally focused on binaries and single
single execution single executables by
broadcasting our town' messages on the
signal network we can have our AOP
cross-cutting concerns handled
system-wide and we get this for free so
now that we've resolved to embrace the
entropy to come of our application by
considering all three major causes of
entropy let's see some examples of
leveraging couches to add our add to our
example app
so now that we've gone through the
process of we want to be able to now add
caching to our server so we're not going
to change anything on the client side
it's still responding to these events
there she's so what I now want to do is
so we had our inline handler for space
find what I'm going to do is add an
intercept handler for space find that's
going to test to see if we're looking
for a specific space and if not we
return and then the in inline handler is
going to be called its then I'm gonna if
if we make it past there I'm gonna go to
Redis and try to get that item if I
didn't find it we missed on the cache
log it and return it'll call the inline
handler if we did we're gonna reset the
contacts to enter Portal and that will
prevent any downstream any downstream
application context from occurring
so that is a cash check now how do we
implement how do we implement storing so
because we're already in our save space
handler we were we were returning the
application context as space stored
we're also broadcasting that on the
server wide signal Network
we'll simply add it at an async handler
globally to anything that's stored and
grab it and stick it in the cache now
this was already working because I undid
all the commenting but I'll go ahead and
show you how that's working
so if we have in Redis we've got our je
s conf we go ahead and hit that and then
we see in our logging cache hit that's
what got returned back to the list this
one due it'll be is not in our cache
will go into that will see cache miss
and by the way all the logging is simply
adding a wild-card handler as an
intercept that never returns anything so
we never intercept we never block we
just see it coming through and that
happens here as well as in our client so
this one was a cache miss but if we go
ahead and edit it will now see that gets
stored in our cache
and the next time we go back to the list
we'll have a cache hit
they come close to at a time ah
so with all this we get a lot of
additional benefits we're building on an
architecture designed to evolve by
embracing the entropy inherent in our
systems it's completely composable and
decoupled from day zero you have the
ability to use the best tool for the job
so because everything is just a handler
you can use whatever you want we get to
build reactive applications that come
with the common semantics across all of
the execution stacks we get like I said
aspect-oriented programming system-wide
for free we're getting a stream of
events with rich metadata that we can
then use for reporting and tracking and
by using this cow message concept these
trigrams it provides a ubiquitous
language like we talked about from
domain-driven design that we get to use
with our non-technical and our product
members of our team and then this same
language ends up translating directly
into the into the code more things to
come tools meta description files
decorators testing and debugging tools
at the moment it's a little verbose but
by creating meta description files we
can wire this stuff up on the side
router for manipulating and reacting to
URL paths middleware and adapters for
different front-end components wrappers
for the different fast providers and a
towel mesh that would be able to conjoin
signal networks to make that aspect
seamless as well as implementations
beyond JavaScript so you can have
handlers implemented in any language
that basically can support this simple
paradigm what do I need from
y'all please try it out this is brand
new this is from a lot of years of me
thinking about this problem and
especially I want you to tell me what's
wrong with it
I do believe in this paradigm as a
simplified way of building applications
and using the strengths of our tools
rather than fighting against them as
we're dealing with various entropy
there is no sponsor it's just me so if
anybody wants to contribute it's all
open source feel free to to share your
feedback and and please come talk to be
more if you're interested in working on
a project that makes that makes it
easier to build applications quickly
where you're not having to worry about
the underlying architecture which can
evolve with you thank you very much I
want to thank everybody at Jay's comp
the hospitality here has been amazing
and thank you all for attending
[Applause]